an eerie silence hangs over kharkiv
with apocalyptic scenes
the center of the city
frozen like a page in history
standing still for the world to see
there was a huge explosion uh that might
was heard all over the city center i
lived quite close so i myself heard it
and the the walls were shaken and after
that there were several another
airstrikes and in the following days i
walked in the streets thousands of times
and there were so many like little
coffee shops or restaurants on the first
floors here and people were living here
my friends were living in these houses
and so now there is no place where they
can come back
since the start of the war maria has
refused to leave her home city in
northeastern ukraine
she stayed to document what the russians
are doing
here during the nazi occupation so even
the nazis during the world war ii didn't
destroy the buildings and now they are
in ruins because of the russians who are
our neighbors
people here think that one day soon the
damage can be fixed and buildings
reconstructed
but the impact of the war on the minds
of people in kharkiv will be harder to
overcome the russians thought they could
just walk in and take this city but they
were mistaken they were met with fierce
ukrainian resistance
and as a result to punish kharkiv the
ripped out its historical heart
for weeks there's been bombing day and
night
once a city of 1.5 million many have
left
some of those who remain struggle for
food
this man brought frozen chickens and
bread to donate to those in need
i hope they will end soon so that our
children can live may wouldn't be gone
and as the sound of artillery fills the
sky
people head to the underground station
to hunker down for the night
every space is taken
including inside the trains
i'm sleeping here we took the mattress
and pumped it up and more or less
settled down
some people sleep here or on the floor
we also eat here the food is so so
volunteers bring it to us
but as the doors on the subway are
closed for the night there's hope here
the next day will bring an end to the
war
and no need to hide from the bombs
assad beg al-jazeera kharkiv